[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8
débat du changement dans le domaine de
la santé oms vaccin infantile devienne
obligatoire à partir du 1er janvier 2018
c'est ce qu'a annoncé la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé agnès buzyn
nous passerons donc de 3 à 11 problème
en france plus de 40% de la population
sud et vaccins en cause les soupçons qui
pèsent sur certains adjuvants comme
l'aluminium ou bien le caractère
obligatoire de la vaccination qui pose
problème pour certains français
alors acte collectif ou consentement
libre du patient pourquoi la vaccination
fait débat en plateau pour en débattre
docteur benoît couderc pardon médecin
responsable du service vaccination dans
les yvelines et jean-paul pelé président
du mouvement pour le respect des droits
fondamentaux de la personne est membre
de l'ue nax l'unité nationale des
associations citoyennes de santé bonsoir
à tous les deux et bienvenus bonsoir
alors pour commencer ce débat je vous
propose de visionner ce micro trottoir
réalisé par axel d'eau est belle et
patrick jacques de dixmude
j'ai l'impression que maintenant on a
pris en otage tout simplement
donc on n'a pas le choix tant que c'est
pour la protection et la prévention des
maladies moi je suis favorable à sa part
principe ça me paraît beaucoup
honnêtement je suis content mais après
plus pour les effets secondaires ou à la
les effets secondaires va bien je suis
pas du tout inquiète je pense que c'est
légitime
il faut vacciner les enfants et de
l'aluminium il ya plein de cochonneries
dedans et je trouve qu'ils sont trop
petits pour supporter tout ça quand
séparemment il ya des additifs qui
supporte mal les enfants et moi mon
enfant avec deux essais très mal réagir
déjà ça ne m'inquiète pas
après faut juger de la pertinence de
seria des populations plus enclins à
avoir ce type de pathologie à sujet qui
fait débat et qui fait réagir on va
revenir sur sur ses déclarations
11 ça fait beaucoup c'est ce qui est dit
deux paires couderc jusqu'à présent nous
n'avions que trois vaccins à faire alors
pourquoi onze d'un coup tout de suite
remettez en passe de 3 obligatoire 11
obligatoire mais onze vaccins sont déjà
fait depuis des années
mettons qu'il nous protège
malheureusement comme vous l'avez dit la
couverture vaccinale en france n'est pas
optimale au contraire de plein d'autres
pays et on prend l'exemple ou la
rougeole vient de disparaître aux états
unis en france elle est trop présente
maladie grave qu'il faut se faire
vacciner donc effectivement rougeole
oreillons rubéole qui sont contenus dans
la même dans le même vaccin vont être
obligatoire l'intérêt c'est de diminuer
d'augmenter la couverture nationale pour
diminuer la contagiosité cette maladie
est trop petit pour supporter tout ça
c'est ce qu'il dit aussi alors imposé
aux vaccins au moins 2 ans à un bébé
c'est pas un peu beaucoup d'un coup
est ce que on se posait la question si
des tests ont été faits par exemple sur
des
est ce que ça vous inquiète par exemple
tout à fait on passe de trois vaccins
obligatoires à 11
il ya déjà qui faisait uniquement
minimum légal et qui refusaient certains
vaccins comme le rer
parce que le rer pose problème malgré
tout en multiplie le nombre de nombre de
vaccinations s'en servent d'une
culpabilisation des parents il faut
accepter d'un phare x etc etc
on a aussi de plus en plus d'accidents
avec surtout avec des cocktails comme el
fares arickx plus prevenar on a une
gamine il n'y a pas très longtemps qui
est morte dans l'ordre cocktail et
france la droite elle était tout petit
je crois qu'elle avait deux mois j'ai
l'article de journal
donc tout de suite après ce cocktail
vaccinal réalise adaptés mis la gamine a
fait 42 et demi de fièvre des
convulsions
elle est tombée dans le coma et ne
restait plus d'un mois dans le coma elle
est morte et des camps comme ça on en a
de plus en plus en belgique ngân in-stat
ci qui est décédé également après le
même cocktail vaccinal et sa soeur
jumelle a développé des graves
complications ont été vaccinées la même
manière vous même moment donc
inquiétudes des cas des cas réels vous
fallait agir lui on ne peut pas laisser
dire ça on peut pas d'une part dire que
les vaccins protègent mahdi grave je
rappelle pour ce que vous citiez la
rougeole il y à un mort sur 1000
l'épidémie de rougeole sévit encore en
france il y a des séquelles
neurologiques et bien plus que des
accidents que vous relatez et dont on
n'a jamais prouvé actuellement le lien
de causalité
il y a eu une grande polémique sur les
vaccins d'hépatite b
moi en tant que médecin je vois encore
des gens porteurs de l'hépatite b qui
vont mourir de cancer de cirrhose
donc il faut toujours voir si vous
voulez pourquoi on protège un vaccin et
la survie ces maladies graves ne
trouvait pas des contre exemples que
vous médiatisé à tort la sclérose en
plaques est un bon exemple
la sclérose en plaques est une maladie
très grave et il faut qu'on progresse et
qu'on recherche il n'a pas de vaccin
mais n'allons pas dire et ça c'est
prouvé qu'il y a un lien de causalité
donc fait très attention
un médecin ne vaccinent pas contre les
ados je peux vous dire il y eu un enfant
mort de tétanos en france
ce qui n'était pas arrivé depuis
longtemps donc attention aux effets
médiatiques de petite échelle et de
journaux qui n'ont aucun fondement et
que vous sortez leur parle aux documents
scientifiques
est ce que vous connaissez les
statistiques du professeur tardieu qui a
donné publiquement des chiffres très
inquiétants
il a vu une montée des attentes de la
myéline c'est une jeune enfant qui
correspondent à la montée de la
vaccination
c'est quand même très curieux avant il y
avait très peu d'enfants qui développe
et des et maladies de la myéline est
depuis qu'on a vexé qu'on a lancé
l'arrestation du petit b on a vu se
multiplier les cas ça c'est le docteur
tarrieu grands professeurs qui le disent
pas là monsieur alors il y à déjà je ne
connais pas et je n'ai pas la chance de
connaître le professeur à dieu moi je me
réfère au conseil de santé publique à
des choses qui viennent de
l'organisation mondiale de santé donc
des références et des bases
scientifiques
on a eu un professeur qui n'est exclue
du conseil de l'ordre pour avoir fait
signer une pétition
donc je respecte tout à fait le
professeur d'art dieu mais je pense qu'à
un moment donné le mélange et
l'utilisation de données scientifiques
non validées ou notre produit pas les
échelles paraît trop facile aujourd'hui
ce qui est sûr ça c'est une donnée sûr
c'est que depuis l'avancé des vaccins on
a pris l'exemple de rougeole oreillons
rubéole mais on pourrait reprendre cette
annonce c'est qu'on voit la mortalité
voir la morbidité les complications des
maladies infantiles largement diminué la
rubéole le fait de vaccination est belle
avec un suivi de sérologie permet
d'éviter des avortements des fausses
couches et ou des malformations ça vous
ne pouvez pas le nier
parce que ça c'est des chiffres s'est
défait après effectivement la communauté
médicale
on n'a jamais nié si vous voulez
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle le bénéfice
risque mais pas dans les proportions que
vous donnez et vous utilisez comme cela
a été fait pour la sclérose en plaques
et le vaccin de l'hépatite b avec dès
aujourd'hui où on sait qu'il n'ya aucun
lien de causalité mais aucun lien de
causalité ça ne veut pas dire il n'y a
aucun lien de causalité entre la
sclérose en plaques et la vaccination ce
soit celles de l'hépatite ou du gardasil
alors j'aimerais qu'on poursuive sur les
effets secondaires justement est ce père
qui dit dans le sujet donc mon enfant a
très mal réagi à un vaccin selon une
étude financée par l' agence du
médicament la haine s m une étude datant
de mars du professeur gherardi la
présence d'aluminium dans les vaccins
pourraient pour certains patients
entraîner un risque pour la santé
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
prend le risque ou est ce qu on pousse
les études docteur cette même étude
puisque récemment effectivement et on se
doit de faire de la recherche donc là
ses chances nationale de sécurité du
médicament a récemment publié une étude
sur effectivement les recherches de
neurotoxicité donc actuellement chez la
souris
mais attention les études sont pas
forcément transposable de la souris on a
et ce même les mêmes délégués la haine
sm on redit aujourd'hui on a plus de 100
millions de recul par rapport à la
vaccination est donc sur les effets
bénéfiques qui sont bien plus forts on
oublie souvent le côté positif de la
vaccination pour de montrer donc
aujourd'hui voilà donc sur les adjuvants
qui sont le minimum c'est actuellement
le meilleur à du vent pour que le vaccin
soit efficace
on espère tous que l'aluminium dans les
déodorants c'est mauvais ça nage je
pense on ne peut pas d'abord il n'y a
aucune preuve et où vous savez bien
qu'il ya une espèce de mode on à
l'aluminium qui recouvre le chocolat et
tout le monde continue à manger du
chocolat depuis des années et on n'a pas
complètement changé à tout le temps les
emballages donc l'aluminium est un
produit très utilisé la recherche fait
qu'effectivement en avance aujourd'hui
la du vent et le meilleur à du vent pour
l'aluminium est le meilleur a du vent
pour l'efficacité et diminuer ses effets
alors après il faut s'entendre sur les
effets secondaires les plus fréquents
sas a toujours dit il
médecin doit l'expliquer et qui sont
survenus de fièvre et donc chez le jeune
enfant effectivement la prévention par
des médicaments antipyrétiques pour
diminuer cette chèvre et savoir que tous
les effets indésirables sont recensés et
reconnus et qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui les
mac les vagues 500 sur le marché n'ont
pas d'effets secondaires prouver qu'ils
quittent ils effraient retirés du marché
alors je veux répondre sont énormes
parce que on n'a pas toujours utilisés
l'aluminium c'est pas vrai avant
d'utiliser du phosphate de calcium où il
est utilisé depuis que la depuis que
l'institut pasteur s'est détachée de sa
branche commerciale et l'a revendue à
mairieux merlieux fabriquer des gens des
25 d'aluminium pour lui c'était plus
simple de continuer de l'aluminium il se
dit moi j'utilise pas le faux sacs de
tissu
je continue en aluminium c'est comme ça
qu'on vaccine évolué milieu
sauf que il ya quand même des gens
sérieux qui écrivent des crêpes des
choses alarmant sur les lumières de la
voiture de la vaccination
c'est un ouvrage universitaire qui a été
supervisé par admet lula qui est une
grande spécialiste des vaccinations et
qui pasteurienne sens pour ça or elle
dit que effectivement l'aluminium pose
problème vous pouvez je peux le vous
lire si vous voulez pas ça vous sortez
des livres d'auteurs unique
moi je vous donne des références qui
sont le haut conseil de santé publique
où il ya des multitudes d'experts ou le
haut quand le haut conseil de santé
publique a fait un rapport il ya deux
ans sur les adjuvants l'aluminium
on peut reconnaître que ce n'est pas
actuellement le meilleur à du vent sauf
que c'est le meilleur actuellement pour
avoir une efficacité des vaccins 1926
fausse y redire l'histoire des vaccins
effectivement la typhoïde ou la
coqueluche
le produit s'est largement améliorée
avec une diminution des effets
secondaires la coqueluche du encore des
nourrissons par l'aplomb le excusez moi
on va avancer une reste peu de temps sur
la déclaration d'agnès busan je veux
rendre la confiance de la vaccination
par l'obligation alors il semble que les
questionnant les questionnements quand
même émergent parce qu'il ya un manque
d'information peut-être un manque de
transparence de l'état
alors ne faut-il pas rendre la confiance
par l'information plutôt ce sera la
dernière question je vous donne la
parole
il faut rendre la confiance aux jeunes
en respectant la déontologie médicale
c'est-à-dire un renonçant à l'obligation
vaccinale
la contrainte est absolument scandaleux
c'est contraire à la déontologie
médicale
le droit reçues en matière médicale est
écrit dans le code de la santé publique
c'est écrit dans le code civil
la france a signé deux traités
internationaux la convention d'oviedo et
la charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne qui prévoit le droit
au fure matière médicale qui prévoit le
respect de l'intégrité physique de la
personne
donc le liberté de choix ce principe
fondamental la déontologie médicale moi
je m'étonne que des médecins ne
comprennent pas ça vous en tant que
médecin et vous avez prêté votre
charmante médecins dont vous avez prêté
serment d'obéir de respecter le code de
déontologie et vous êtes pour la
contrainte vaccinale ça c'est tout à
fait normal
donc si madame du havre la confiance aux
français qu'elle commence à renoncer au
principe d'un contrat est alors là les
mois de la seconde d'écart mais la
contrainte fiennes delà du manque de
confiance et la mauvaise couverture donc
moi je vais prendre deux exemples moi
j'ai pas envie que quand j'aurai des
petits enfants probablement rapidement y
meurt de rougeole parce qu'un autre
enfant n'a pas été vaccinés correctement
c'est comme quand je respecte le feu
rouge c'est obligatoire je respecterai
il ya des contraintes effectivement
financière et je ne comprends pas que ce
soit en termes de santé publique
on ne comprennent pas cette notion de
collectivité si vous entendre le
problème en tant que médecin c'est de
respecter les autres le respect des
autres c'est commencer par se vacciner
pour se protéger bien sûr et aussi pour
protéger les merci à tous les deux ça
sera le mot de la fin fin du set 8 débat
consacré à la vaccination ce soir
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté sur les
sociaux bonne soirée et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]